[Music]
you are the most confident of any guests
that I've talked to thank you very much
of doing this you I was born with
greatness
you nicknamed yourself the chick magnet
well that's one of many I was the monk
of mojo the Grand Wizard of lust demon
of desire soldier of seduction Emperor
of excellence personification of
perfection I mean those are just a
couple things that I have named myself
over the years over there's quite the
ladies foul always found you
irresistible is that right well I can't
help it but uh ladies hands off because
I just got engaged
[Applause]
the women are applauding that you're
engaged he's off the market come on man
are you kidding me yeah I'm dishing it
out can you handle the boyish good looks
the charming personality I dress well
let me come on what woman wouldn't want
this Trevor that's an amazing suit
that's thank you very much actually ever
been more tempered to play tic-tac-toe
on somebody who is your suit made by
because mine was made by really really
pretty blond girls oh my god incredible
major Sears come on all right yeah you
don't want a piece of this actually feel
these these are incredible I take that's
that's quite all right you uh you
traveled the world recently with the WWE
and you brought your your swagger to all
parts of the globe here's a picture of
you at the pyramids wouldn't why is what
is this pose say to us this says I'm
here I'm in Egypt and I'm on a camel
yeah well the picture says that without
you doing any good
here you are at the Sydney Opera House
again doing your with your Jersey Shore
birthday parties Jersey sure was cool
Conan okay like you built the Opera
House look at that code if he said look
good on me you know it's funny when I
was doing these picks for this this
photos yeah I wasn't planning on people
laughing at them I was thinking oh man
wow the Miz is at the Opera House oh
cool oh yeah laughter yeah well I guess
you ain't STONER your plan didn't go
quite as you wanted to tell you that's
not them is where you are the Kremlin
we're at all look at that Here I am
Conan and by the way every time we go to
a new country I always speak the
language whether it's Russian whether
its Arabic French Dutch Flemish I've
spoken Italian Spanish you name it I've
spoken it in every single country you
speak every language I don't speak it
but I tell them hey how do I see these
words in your dialect and then I go out
there and sometimes I bomb sometimes I
don't it doesn't really matter
what a great and wise world traveler
they appreciate that tell me what noises
to make with my days please appreciate
the fact that I'm trying Conan okay
patronizing is an international language